Look at this map of all of
the places in the world
Vladimir Putin can't go
It's the countries in green.
Let me explain.
The International Criminal Court
is this court in the Netherlands
that is in charge of prosecuting,
like the worst war
criminals in our world.
They recently put a warrant out
for the arrest of Vladimir Putin
for his war crimes in Ukraine,
which means that everyone who has signed
on to the International Criminal Court,
all of these countries, must arrest
Vladimir Putin
if he enters their country.
And guess who just joined...
Russia's neighbor and old ally, Armenia.
Armenia did this
because they're worried
about a whole other issue
with Azerbaijan,
which I explained in another video.
But in doing so,
they made Russia very angry
because they're basically validating
the court who wants to arrest
Vladimir Putin.
Russia used to support Armenia,
but they've kind of been absent
lately, largely
because they're focused on Ukraine.
So Armenia is like,
I have nothing to lose by signing on
and kind of estranging myself
with Russia.
So, they signed on; they’re
part of the ICC.
And Russia's not happy about it.
If you want to understand
global politics, follow along for more.